happy tuesday everyone i hope you all
had a glorious labor day i know i did
but i got to be honest with you i do
miss cats
she's still on her honeymoon
so let's check in and see how those
lovebirds are doing
i think we know which one is which
[Laughter]
so this labor day while the rest of us
were barbecuing or picnicking or if
you're me barbecuing a picnic
what was our president up to was he busy
trying to soothe the country after last
week's speech
you remember that speech right
here's a clip
yeah
now you think he might want to repair
the damage he's done you know with some
unifying words for the holiday but you'd
be wrong instead he tweeted this
he said old joe says mega proposals maga
proposals are a threat to the very soul
of the country
so he does this over a holiday
you know i'd say he's tone deaf
but he can't hear me
so magga proposals
what could that mean i mean it kind of
sounds like fun
we had one of the most successful
presidencies in history including an
economy
that was the envy of the world
thank you very much do you want to get
married
do i
quickly
oh good
dearly beloved we are gathered here to
join this couple in holy magamony
do you promise to love honor and cherish
despite the losers the haters and the
fake news i do
do you promise to make america great
again in sickness and in health even
though your doctor has said you are the
healthiest bride in the history of
brides i do
by the power vested in me by the
atlantic city gaming commission i now
pronounce you
man
wife a threat to democracy and members
of mar-a-lago
[Applause]
hey guys
wednesday night is five-star seafood
night
my advice to trump because i know he
watches you got to add that to the
rallies maga proposals mega weddings and
if things don't work out maga divorces
although the fight over who gets to my
pillow could get ugly
so as we face runaway crime and
inflation diaper joe is fixated on magga
magamag everything is magga including
his gibberish this guy spouts more
rubbish than a busted trash compactor
but i wonder if his name is joe biden
and is he still jill biden's husband
my name is joe biden i am jill biden's
husband
and i want to start by saying
any child
under
12 years of age deserves a little extra
ice cream or something for doing this
this has got to be the most boring thing
in the world for you honey
honey
honey hold on there ponytail puller
keep your distance
you know it's funny joe's rallies are
the only places where the secret service
protects people from him
but look everyone is entitled to be an
idiot
look everybody's entitled to be an idiot
i think he found his campaign slogan for
2024.
but what about those extreme maga
republicans i bet they don't just
threaten our personal rights and
economic security
extreme mega-republican doses threaten
our personal rights
and our economic security
they embrace political violence yes
they embrace political violence says the
guy who hid under a bed like a crusty
sock
during the george floyd riots
he is like a krusty sock but at least we
beat pharma
we beat farmer this year
we beat farmer this year and it mattered
we're going to change people's lives
oh my god he should tell pharma that
they got beat while they're counting the
trillion dollar plus in revenue they
made last year thanks to biden
well at least he's done with those
extreme mega republicans right
the extreme micro republicans in
congress have chosen to go backwards
full of anger violence hate and division
uh anger violence hate division
you know i'm thinking he doesn't like us
[Laughter]
anyway in the face of bad news joe's joe
tries to bury it with fear he's like a
guy who tries to hide a bald spot with
spray paint just like just like jesse
waters
so now it's a civil war over a nation's
soul but what gives joe the soul man the
soul come on you know what the soul is
it the the the the the thing
look the thing you can't see
all right
like on uh a shoe where's the soul it's
on the bottom you can't see it
you don't say it come on
give me a break
get out of my face man look
i i said it before i'll say it again
everyone is entitled to be an idiot
and never before in the history of this
country
have more people had that opportunity
than under this administration
i think i said that right
sadly he's not
he's not the only one trying to gin up a
phantom civil war our so-called
historians have gone from historical to
hysterical
first this jackass suggested trump
should be executed for treason which
should be enough to get this dude into a
loony bin but he can't stop
certainly there was a specter of
violence uh throughout american history
for many americans and in
uh 1860 a national civil war but you
didn't have an ex-president or a
president calling for it same thing in
the 1930s there were fascist leaders
this is the first time in american
history that we have someone who used to
be president of the united states
you got to give him credit he hit the
civil war and hitler in one comparison
it's a shame he left up bin laden and
freddy krueger
some historian but he's not alone i
wonder if this dope has the scoop on the
ultra right maggot contingent
there is an ultra right
mega um contention in this country that
wants to overthrow the us government
that despises our institutions our
constitutional foundations because they
believe in a deep state conspiracy and
they cling to it
now i assumed historians are supposed to
write about the civil war not encourage
it
and didn't it used to be a rather staid
profession someone wearing glasses a
tweed jacket with suede patches on the
elbows and smoking a pipe now they're as
unbalanced as paul pelosi taking a field
sobriety test
they're little girls on twitter
what world are these people living in do
they ever go outside or are they
nocturnal like raccoons so if you see
one out during the day it means he's
rabid
but the media is with him too
these days it feels like we are not just
at the brink of a civil war but that one
has already begun trump supporters are
already speaking the language of
violence what a fun house mirror to
reality these freaks accuse you of civil
war when you just want a civil life
no wonder they can't offer any evidence
but joe wants you to think it's 1864
which is the last year he had a solid
bowel movement
but you know what i'll listen to bill
burr
people are getting their information on
the internet so they think that a lot of
people you know if you go on the
internet everybody seems like they're
angry but if you go outside and walk
around the knot it's like they're just
walking around screaming at each other
there's the
i think the internet is just like an
abusive relationship now he's not the
first person to say this but it's worth
noting we have entire industries
invested in these psychological war
games but it's all in their minds mainly
because there's not much else in there
and there's no war going on with your
neighbors unless it's a shooting one in
chicago
true there's violence on city streets
but politicians don't mind that after
all they're surrounded by more security
than the pope running into the vatican
costco for tube socks
that was strange they wouldn't want to
buy tube socks
as long as they're not crusty
so they claim it's a war for the soul of
america but we know better we depend on
the constitution not the soul we aren't
interested in overturning anything
except the overturners the people who
want to change the constitution the
people who use government agencies
against you leaders who use the same
agencies to protect their criminal kin
we're not the radicals here they are
because i don't try to change things
that i love whether it's my country or
my underwear
it's true i've been wearing these boxers
since the 4th of july
[Applause]
welcome tonight's guests
he's so wholesome laura ingalls sent him
a friend with crass fox's contributor
tom salu
her pronouns are she and she hit
fox business anchor deagan mcdowell
and you can't believe that
as a bilingual pundit she ticks off
liberals in english and spanish former
white house strategic communications
director mercedes
[Applause]
and he gets fashion advice from hobos
and happy endings from junkies host of
fox across america jimmy failure there
it is
tom great to see you i like how you kind
of like you got a nice
look going there well i try to step it
up when fail is on the panel here you
usually have to step down when he's on
by the way fella which uh member of the
ojs did you murder
[Laughter]
i'm not even coming back because you
were out last week and you hooked me up
i got to sit in your seat on the five
which was a career highlight and the
first time i've sat in a high chair
before which is a big deal
so
just thank you just thank you
what do you make of the whole maga
proposal thing oh i mean
it becomes it's so idiotic usually you
talk about okay the the reality of the
situation and then the politics of the
situation but i can't even address the
reality of the situation because it's
it's like opposite world yeah you know
and i think it's i think at this point
biden is like a celebrity like a
high-level celebrity you know when
you're like sinatra or elvis and you're
surrounded by yes men but
his he's surrounded by the media yes man
because when he started the campaign he
started with the charlottesville lie the
very fine people and the media said yes
to him and he continues to lie he lies
and the media says yes to him so why
would he ever stop doing it yes he's
been enabled yes that's true and you
know what uh it's a good point to bring
up the media degan because whenever they
thought that donald trump was stoking
hate they would say so like oh my god
he's a hate monger he's a hate monger
we're basically only talking about what
people wanted but they when when biden
does it over a holiday a holiday they're
behind them it's crazy well they don't
have any new material yeah it's like
much like jimmy
[Music]
you know it's 20 22 i'm still waiting
for those village people jokes
he does that a lot yeah you know i've
been paddling
around the liberal bilgewater of new
york too long so i would call my daddy
on this and ask him
dao
what do you think of what beschloss and
brinkley are saying about you folks down
there and he'd go
butt floss and binky what the hell kind
of band is that
i don't have time for this
i got to go borrow some gasoline from my
neighbors to finish cutting the grass
and then drive over two counties to go
buy some milk i heard that was on sale
and then come back and reheat an
iffy pork chop for dinner
because people are struggling uh in the
minds and eyes and mouths of all the
media and everybody in biden
incorporated
conservatives have to be
a nameless faceless mob
otherwise well when they have names
and faces and families you have to
acknowledge the rising financial pain
and struggles that you have caused
that's a very good point so mercedes
being a veteran of the white house how
do you respond when when uh the other
side is coming in with fear because fear
is an effective tool right on every side
and and fears are real like when i talk
about crime it's because i'm
legitimately scared i'm going to get
mugged and or the country's going in a
bad direction how does the how do the
republicans respond to this attack well
first of all i'm a proud maga republican
and i think what we find is that these
maga republicans it's simple they love
america and if they're going to go after
grandma sue who's probably watching her
show right now
and sweet and louise
they've got a big problem because these
individuals what they want to do is they
want to stand up for the wonderful
values these about it's about freedom
it's about opportunity for their
families
and you've got this
in the white house who won't even go
after antifa or black lives matter that
burn down these cities
yet they go after us like we're the
criminals i mean i think it's pure
propaganda i think it's a losing
political strategy and i think at the
end of the day it's going to backfire
for joe biden and the democrats because
you know what they're trying to do
they're just trying to save the blue
districts they're trying to make sure
that their liberal base goes out because
they're scared of the red wave that's
going to come because it is going to
come in november well i don't know i'm a
little
i'm a little bit
i don't like saying red waves oh stop
kind of like like when i was a kid and i
wanted a red bicycle for christmas and
it didn't come
you know instead i got the people's
almanac
i'm not joking by the way jimmy what do
you make of that contrast between the
the psychological uh fantasy of there's
this war but outside everything's great
i mean
i think that part's true like bill barr
makes a good point though
bill burr bill barr who's also great yes
very similar styles a lot of people
don't know that
barr gets rad late at night get him to a
happy hour yeah uh he will be on my
radio show tomorrow by the way so if
anybody's into that uh but stick with me
okay bill burr is right in that internet
twitter social media yeah uh twitter is
a fight club for people who don't want
to get hit we know that people go there
to just get into conflicts and their
thing and the way they go but to the
biden strategy okay and i think
everybody is mistaking this because they
keep saying biden's running on magger
republicans because he doesn't want to
run on his record but let's not forget
the obvious that he might just think
it's 2020. you know what i mean yeah
and like they sat down with him to talk
about the midterms he started railing
about rag and megan somebody's like
should we cut him off and they're like
no no go with it this might work this
might work and i think that's a little
bit of what's going on he finally got
let out of the house and he thinks he's
doing his 20 20 campaigning you know
what might be the safest bet but the
only thing i was going to say well the
only thing i was going to say about that
is the reason nobody's buying it is
because he keeps making the claim of
what these maga republicans don't accept
the results of an election but by that
standard you should lock up every
democrat from 2016 including karine
jean-pierre yeah so essentially right
now biden is willie nelson telling the
rest of us we need to stop smoking pot
and we're like yo willy i think you're
missing the forest through the trees you
know what i'm saying hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else